death sentences handed down to two
british men captured in ukraine our
correspondent uh ali bunkel is uh in
southern eastern ukraine and joins us
with some reaction to this uh on the
phone and and they just remind us
that these these two british nationals
and the moroccan one as well um when
they were captured and how this is all
unfolded
yeah they were both they were both
fighting um for ukrainian forces uh
at the
start of the uh the conflict here back
in february um they were both here for
very different reasons but essentially
because they had um relationships with
with ukrainians and they had been uh had
a relationship with the country for some
years so they weren't
directly part of the thousands of
foreign legion fighters who came over
after the start of the war but they were
fighting in the east they were captured
i think back in april and they were
sentenced and put on trial by by the
russians now i think the fear is that
the russians are making an example
of them partly because they are british
and the british have been heavily
involved in arming the ukrainians the
russian government has
repeatedly singled out britain in
particular for the help that that's been
giving the russians
but also i think they are making a point
against foreign fighters as well but
this was not uh the expected uh sentence
a death sentence handed down to these
three men the foreign office in the uk
said they've been following it closely
they have repeatedly made statements
saying that the men should be treated
according to the geneva convention as
prisoners of war
but they have been on trial in donetsk
which is
held by
russian forces at the moment and they
have reportedly were told admitted to
crimes of and this is the charge against
them training uh people for terror acts
and the sentence they've got is a death
sentence which will i think come as a
shock to anybody who is uh who's
following a shock to their families and
shocked the british government who uh
have pleaded that they are treated as
prisoners of war
and and uh you mentioned the foreign
office there i mean i i guess they
weren't expecting as you said this to be
the outcome what's likely to be the
response from here
i think the foreign office and british
government's in quite a difficult
position uh on the one hand there was a
slightly muddled um advice coming from
the british government as to whether
people should come
and help out the ukrainians and fight in
the conflict here you might remember the
foreign secretary liz truss uh so
basically giving it her backing and then
that was criticized by the defense
secretary ben wallace
it was always going to be difficult when
you start introducing foreign fighters
into a conflict because although the
ukrainians welcomed it they they had a
and i i met people who were
in charge of this of the administration
of the foreign legion and they had quite
a substantial uh recruitment process by
bringing people in but the risk was you
were always going to have the potential
of britain's or other nationalities
americans perhaps being captured by
russian forces and then what the
russians would do with that and how they
would spin it for example and so i think
the british government will will have an
obligation because these these two men
are british nationals they'll have an
obligation to uh keep pressuring the uh
russian government uh to at least lessen
the sentence from being a death sentence
uh but at the same time
they have to retain what has now become
their line that they do not support
people coming to this country to fight